le Hamas est d'abord une idéologie qui
n'est pas que celle du Hamas parce
qu'elle est aussi celle de l'Iran et on
n'est pas très surpris qui est la
destruction d'Israël et donc tant qu'on
aura pas trouvé un moyen d'établir une
paix définitive cette idéologie
perdurera et donc ça vous ne pourrez pas
l'éliminer donc la réponse n'est pas que
militaire la réponse n'est pas que dans
dans ce que va faire Israël sur le
terrain depuis le début du monde la
guerre n'apporte jamais de solution à
quoi sert la guerre la guerre sert
toujours à changer les conditions
politiques d'où doit émerger une paix
meilleure que la précédente donc la
solution n'est jamais militaire la la
guerre est un moyen pour une fin et la
fin doit toujours être politique et il
n'y aura pas de paix au Moyen-Orient
tant qu'il n'y aura pas une perspective
de paix et de liberté pour le pour les
Palestiniens c'est comme ça et donc le
le le reproche qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui on sait pas tout ce qui se
passe mais cette guerre semble être
conduite par un souci vengence et on le
comprend bien mais surtout pour
elle-même or une stratégie ne fonctionne
que si elle vise un but positif et
jamais un but négatif là cette guerre
elle veut détruire une stratégie ne
fonctionne que si elle cherche à
construire quelque chose et si la
destruction n'est jamais qu'une marche
pour aller vers cette
construction